le premier tour des législatives
arrivent à grands pas et si on se
demande encore comment pour se présenter
certains candidats c'est-à-dire
un chauffard et les polémiques ne se
font pas que sur les plateaux télé mais
aussi dans les tracts pascal richard
candidat de la majorité dans la première
circonscription de la somme s'est fait
remarquer pour sept qualifiés comme
français de souche une expression
souvent associé à l'extrême droite qui
n'a pas forcément ravi des électeurs du
parti renaissance les matroni ceux qui
parlent d'un en tant que français de
souche sait quel genre de virage à
droite sur son compte twitter pascal
ricard a réagi mettant fin à toute
polémique j'assume totalement ce qui est
écrit ça veut dire quoi une connotation
finalement ce n'est pas parce qu'un
groupe saura pas qu'on ne peut pas
l'utiliser on a autre chose à faire que
de la sémantique alors un candidat de la
majorité se dit français de souche dans
son tract pour les législatives
comprenez vous le tenez
alors comment avez-vous le sol et oui
j'y garde alors oui dans sa
circonscription marine le pen a fait 30%
conscription de la somme 30% donc il va
draguer l'électorat de marine le pen
c'est je trouve que faire ça franchement
c'est pas bien parce que c'est purement
électoralistes purement démagogique et
je trouve qui renie ses convictions
capter quelques voix donc je comprends
tout à fait la polémique mais s'il sera
plein de françois ruffin
je pense qu'il s'est trompé de parti il
faut qu'il aille chez eric zemmour chez
marine le pen moi l'expression français
de souche je la trouve insupportable
parce qu'elle sous-entend qu'il ya des
bons français et d'un mauvais français
qui a des français pur et des français -
pur comme si le fait d'avoir une
ascendance étrangère était quelque chose
de sale donc soit il a commis une grosse
erreur il doit s'excuser mais
visiblement il ne fait pas soyez de
changer de parti oui mais même cette
réponse elle est scandaleuse moi je vais
vous dire si gt alarm ce qui n'est pas
le cas parce que je me suis dit oh comme
la reine la reine la république en
marche puisqu'il fait partie de la
république marc cerrone est maintenant
passé renaissance
[Musique]
lagarde et moi je vais lescure en fait
tu vas juste garder
quand il ya des petits fours à gratter
tu viens
tu bouffes de thor d'auto de trucs en 2d
utilisateurs il arrivait bravo françois
hollande
bernadette chirac se
demanderait ce n'est cependant pour les
pitchouns à lewis et demanderait son
exclusion oui je suis d'accord avec
gilles effectivement marine le pen a
fait 30 % donc c'est clairement
électoraliste et quand et par ailleurs
il ajoutant un second argument qui pour
moi ne vaut pas il dit qu'en face de lui
et la rue fin qui est habitué des propos
outranciers et que donc lui se sont
autorisés à avoir lui aussi des propos
outranciers franchement c'est pas parce
que quelqu'un fait un propos outranciers
à ton tour tu dois faire n'importe quoi
donc souffler dans les deux cas c'est
enfin voilà ça ne fonctionne pas viendra
alors le jeu au sol non cgj ouais alors
moi je vais me faire l'avocat du diable
parce qu'effectivement cette formule
elle est très contestable très mal
adjointe évidemment opportunistes
électoralistes après moi j'ai demandé
par exemple moi mon mari il n'est pas du
tout aux français de souche il est
italien il s'est battu sous laniel non
citoyens italiens de souche voilà et
s'est battu pour avoir les papiers
français à l'âge de 18 ans et quand on
lui dit qu'il est pas français de souche
et qui les italiens de souche et qu'il
est français en papier à partir de 10
ans ça lui pose aucun problème il se
sent pas exclue il se sent pas
stigmatiser alors voilà donc je pense
qu'en fait c'est juste une certaine
vision aujourd'hui français de souche
c'est trop connoté effectivement mais je
pense que voilà il faut quand même
relativiser l'expression je vois pas où
est le problème d'être français de
souche et d'avoir des pâtes souvent en
italie avec lui oui j'y vais souvent
savoir à tout le temps au sziget en
italie l'année dernière c'est ce qui
fait toute la costa del sol
on peut être fiers de ces souches est
fier d'avoir aussi des papiers apparaît
qu à partir du moment où on et
régularise donc voilà je vois pas où est
le problème aussi en fait partie alors
il m'a fait pas leur parler parce que je
vais réveiller quelqu'un bonsoir a
commencé là vous demandez certainement
que font tous ces gens
beaucoup d'éclairage non je trouve que
ça devrait être bannie des trucs comme
ça franchement je ne sais pas ce qu'il a
fait dans la somme mois ces députés ça
se trouve il a fait des choses
formidables mais je rejoins je rejoins
berne a en fait pour moi il devrait y
avoir une grosse une grosse sanction
pour ce mec là parce qu'elle peut pas
parler comme ça c'est des sensibilités
de chacun tu dis ton mari ça ne gêne pas
parce que il ay s'est battu pour ça que
j'aime faire les
sales et moi ça me gêne par exemple tu
vois moi ça me jette mon papa il est
marocain j'aime j'aime pas quelqu'un qui
me dit je suis français de chaussures de
souche c'est comme il dit guillaume et
ça veut dire ça voudrait dire qu'il ya
des français meilleur que d'autres banon
bah si c'est quoi qui dit je suis
français de souche pourquoi tu viens
d'être je viens plus de la france que
quelques mois je suis pas une française
de souche est vrai on dis pas que je
suis mal il y est né en france un
immigré un immigré kent en france son
père son père est immigré lui l'aîné en
france est-ce qu'il est plus français
que lui les plus français que les
minerais il dit pas je suis français je
dois soyez pas alors je les maraîchers
français de souche ne viennent pas
l'expression je la trouve assez les
sénateurs merci merci ça va arriver donc
ça va arriver dans quelques heures
restez avec nous merci non
[Rires]
100 heures de nuit deux minutes y'a donc
ils sont tous pareils et en week-end
ils font le pont ils font plus que de
fond le viaduc
ok merci il n'y a plus personne en
russie cei tout le monde s'est barré
merci merci en tout cas vous d'être la
raison vous verrez ah oui alors ils ont
barricadé voilà bravo du rallye n'a non
seulement des forces armées
[Applaudissements]